so let's have a look at this question
together by now i hope you've had the
opportunity to take a screenshot if you
haven't already do it now and whilst i'm
talking um please please please draw
yourself a copy in fact multiple copies
if you have the time of the diagram you
can see there on the right hand side
as with so many geometry questions our
visual reasoning our spatial reasoning
is going to require us to have a diagram
to scroll all over and a decent size
diagram please
i have the distinct advantage of being
able to zoom in and out and make my
diagram magically larger just by
doing that but i would advise that you
make your diagram um like no smaller
than the width of half of your page so
you should be able to fit like four of
this diagram onto a page if you can fit
more of them your diagram is too small
and even up until the most recent
assessment you've still all been drawing
really small diagrams so stop that okay
once you've got the diagram there what's
going on well it says the locus that's a
or locus so that's a word that we've
sort of referred to um in the past it
basically means that complex number zed
can kind of move around
so and it can sort of exist on a set of
different points a subset of the complex
plane that's what we call it now within
the new syllabus so long as it obeys
this particular geometric rule that's
set up in the equation r gives n minus 2
root 3.
take away r of z minus 2 i equals pi on
three it's part of a circle um as you
can see specifically it's a major arc
the one that you can see there running
through a and then up to z and then
across to b
um so you've got that major arc and then
they give you the angle or they define
the angle between the lines from 2i to z
and from 2 root 3 to z they call that
alpha right
show that alpha equals pi on 3. so there
is the first part
several of you have been in the room for
a few minutes so i'm maybe i'm not going
to give you five minutes maybe i'll give
you three especially because we took
some time to have a discussion earlier
in the lesson so it's 7 42 i'm going to
give you 7 45
and um
if you if you're already there please
post in the chat and let me know that i
can move on faster
if that's you
please post it now otherwise i'll give
you a little bit of time i'll shut up
and let you have a go at it
in the silence of your own mind well so
to show that alpha this angle up here um
within this triangle that is within the
circle um to show that it's pi on three
what i need to do is try and get some
information about that triangle abz
but to do that i need to start outside
triangle abz using the information
that's been given to me in the question
okay namely that i've got um
this coordinate 2i for a and then i've
got this coordinate 2 root 3 for b
so i can use that information in
triangle oab which you can see i've
highlighted in orange
because i can see that triangle oab has
to be right angled right i've got the
coordinate axes which are perpendicular
to each other which means i can just use
some right angle triangle trig there to
find angles inside that triangle which
will help me get into triangle a b z and
make some conclusions there okay so hold
on to yeah let's have a go at this i'm
going to start as i mentioned in
triangle oab which i've highlighted in
orange there
and what i can use is the two um
perpendicular lengths that have been
provided to me because they run along
the coordinate axes right so you can see
this is going to be 2 and this is going
to be 2 root 3. by the way
this is not the best diagram in the
world that they've provided to us you
can see the scale is horrendous and i'm
going to come back to that point later
on that there are some things you can
rely on the diagram for and other things
you can't but that's a point that's a
bit of a spoiler which we'll come to you
soon so in triangle oab right i want to
try and understand what's happening with
these angles inside by using the angles
in here and there's a bunch of different
ways to do it but for me the most
obvious thing that i can see is to try
and find out what this angle in the
corner is here triangle o b
a
to find out what that angle is you think
about the sides you've got it's oa and
ob which are the opposite side to that
angle and the adjacent side so clearly
the ratio that can help me here is tan
so i'm going to write tan
of oba
is going to be equal to and then i've
just got opposite on adjacent which in
this case is 2 on 2 root 3. so that's 1
on root three
and hopefully you've got some
exact values in your mind and you can
think about what
angle you take the tan of it and gives
you one on root three that of course is
going to be pi on six so i'm going to
pop that into my diagram right there
okay
now from here i can then say well how do
i use this to reason into the triangle
right well i need to be able to
understand what's going on with this
this statement here and how can i use
that to try and add more useful
information onto the diagram that will
aid my reasoning so you can see r of z
minus two root three like where is that
right that is the argument two zed
from two root three we would normally
say like augz zed's the um
angle the argument measured from the um
from the origin right but that minus two
root three shifts us over to to change
our reference point right we're no
longer measuring from the um origin
we're going to be measuring from this
point over here 2 root 3 so that's the
angle from b
so that's this angle in place over here
and then the next question is where is r
of z minus 2i well again it's the
argument measured from the positive real
direction but our reference point has
changed this time to 2i so where is that
now this is less obvious because a is
not on the coordinate axis so in terms
of like measuring from the positive real
axis b is on the positive real axis so
it's very easy to show that um
that angle in place but with a you
actually have to put in some kind of
line here to indicate the positive real
direction because otherwise you can't
put in r z minus 2i it doesn't have the
right lines to fit between
so therefore once i put this in you can
see measuring from the positive real
direction
up towards z right that a z interval
there that's what r of z minus 2 i is
this angle in here so if you haven't put
this onto your diagram i'd encourage you
to do so
and just to make the next parts of this
easier to deal with i'm going to give
that angle there this angle here i'm
just going to give it a name i'm going
to call it theta that will save me from
writing r of z minus 2i which is very
very tiresome over and over again okay
so having done that on the diagram let's
introduce that a piece of logic into our
working right i'm going to say let r z
minus 2i
let's call that theta now therefore from
the question just looking at this line
that i've highlighted in purple up here
right if i replace that with a theta i
can
express this arg of z minus 2 root 3 in
terms of theta right so i don't need to
call this other angle over here give it
a new name like phi or kappa or whatever
i can state it in terms of theta the
less pronumerals i have the better and
in fact theta's going to be the only one
that i need in addition to the alpha
they've already provided us so i'm going
to just state the original questions
equation but with a theta in place right
so i'm going to say therefore
r of z minus 2 root 3.
instead of saying minus r of n minus 2i
i'm going to say minus theta and that's
equal to pi on 3 according to the
question so i'll just say the reason for
that is that it's given that's what they
told us okay
from there as i mentioned i want to get
r z minus 2 root 3 by itself so i've got
it in terms of theta of course i just
add theta to both sides and that gives
me this so i'm going to pop that onto my
diagram as well that's theta
plus
pi on
3.
which you can see sort of makes sense
because you've got an acute angle over
here and then you've got an obtuse angle
so that adding of pi on 3 fits the sense
check that you might do okay
now that i've done that um how can i get
into what's going on here right well i
hope you can see that triangle um
a b z i now know almost everything i
need to know about it because i can
reason that
triangle or rather this straight line a
uh sorry o b and to the right to the
positive direction i can actually use
those two pieces of information i've
already got to get this final little
angle in here right so what i can say is
let's uh write this
i can say but
using those angles on a straight line so
i'm going to have
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
plus angle
have a look at that carefully that's
going to be a
b
z is the next one along so i'll just put
that in red here
i don't know that yet but i'm about to
express it plus the final angle that i
have over on the right hand side which
is that arg of
z minus 2 root 3.
that should be equal to pi because
that's the angle sum of a straight line
so i'll just drop that down that
reasoning is important
angle sum of straight line
and from here i just need to do some
substitution yeah
i can see that i'm going to have
angle
[ __ ] which i already know is pi on 6
this angle inside the triangle abz is
the unknown and then that r gives n
minus 2 root 3 i just showed that that
was theta plus pi on 3. so that's all
equal to pi
i just need to rearrange this to get a b
z on its own
so i'm going to be subtracting all of
these angles you can see on the left
hand side
for both sides to get me
a nice angle on the right hand side i
will let you confirm for yourself that
that's going to pi on 2 minus theta so
that's what i have there
pi on 2
minus theta okay
now you can see i'm sort of edging my
way into the triangle right i've got
this piece of information here which is
helpful to me and i can go further by
saying one of the reasons why this pi on
6 was useful to me is i wonder if you
noticed by drawing this positive real uh
direction uh vector as it were in there
i've created some parallel lines right
that positive real direction is parallel
to every other positive real direction
that i've got in there including the
positive side of the real axis or the
real axis as a whole so therefore i can
say if i've got pi on 6 right here
i also have pi on 6 here and that's
because
alternate angles on parallel lines are
equal so i'm going to use that to get
into to get my final piece of
information within the triangle and that
will get me alpha okay so i can say then
uh let's look at the angle sum of this
uh triangle abz because now i have all
the pieces right i've got alpha this
angle here will be theta plus pi on six
and this angle here is pi on two minus
theta uh let's write it like this in
order i can say then
angle a b
z
plus angle b a z plus angle a z b that's
all the angles within the triangle
that's going to equal 180 degrees or pi
because we've been doing everything in
radians and that's because the angle sum
of the triangle
abz
and from here i just have to do some
careful substitution a b z is the angle
we just found so that's pi on 2 minus
theta
i'll put that in brackets to separate it
out angle b a z
is this one in here right b
a z so that's going to be theta plus pi
on 6. i do have to be careful here
because i need to say why it's theta
plus pi on six so i'll put that
reasoning at the end of the line in a
second and then a z b
is alpha that's the thing that we're
trying to find right so that's equal to
pi
what was my reasoning for um for this
this angle here being theta plus pi on
six it was the alternate angles right so
i'm just going to put that there
alternate angles
equal
on parallel lines
so
you can see how much of our old geometry
we're using within the complex plane
it's still very important to include
that right
okay so we're pretty close here you can
see my thetas are going to cancel which
is good because my alpha is just
supposed to be an angle by itself i've
got pi take away pi on 2 take away pi on
6 so that's going to be
pi minus 2 pi on 3 which is the pi on 3
that was required so at that point
i am done so i hope that helped you to
see the solution okay